yeah I heard it was not CGI Minnesota so
far away what about you where you from
well define that I mean like where was I
born or where do I live the longest or
like the best Oh c-141 taking off you
see that it's Caroline no Caroline Fifi
isn't Charlie alpha Romeo Oscar no my
name is not charlie he isn't charlie
that looks like a c5 but a c5 is like no
where were you born I guess I was born
in Guam but I only lived there for like
three months so it's really count then I
moved to Germany so then I'm going to
Washington State then Washington DC
oh wow this place is long this is nice
of the O club what's the O club
obeah the officer's club my base kind of
a big deal Texas California Northern
California and then Southern California
two years later but in between that I
moved up Hawaii then we moved to
Virginia yeah so even with this job I
still have like seven years stilling a
pay off my student debt how about you oh
I was actually on the GI Bill in college
then Turkey Okinawa and Japan Illinois
Oklahoma oh my god
you were an Air Force proud also yeah oh
my gosh we must have been it reinstated
the same to me yeah well I'm stuck in a
tlf like the Ramones
so by the time I turned ten we moved to
New Jersey you know able to get my first
tiny card off of Rosie oh you're from
New Jersey were part Oh we were
stationed at Fort Dix I had so much fun
at Fort Dix it was awesome I don't want
to hear you saying I know it's an army
base next an army base for Dix